bonjour anne hidalgo cache de moins en
moins ses ambitions présidentielles
est-ce que selon vous ce serait une
bonne candidate je sais pas si c'est la
candidate idéale en tout cas
manifestement si on en croit la
chronique médiatique elle se poussent du
col elle se verrait bien candidat
l'ennui c'est qu'elle n'est pas la seule
ils sont nombreux christiane taubira
arnaud montebourg françois hollande
lui-même et même laurent joffrin le dit
pas comme ça mais on voit bien que sa
petite entreprise a une une vocation en
tout cas présidentielle donc ils sont
nombreux et tous à peu près sur le même
créneau c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est à dire qu'anne hidalgo l'incarnent
bien en fait le diagnostic que font tous
ces socialistes est le même en gros
voilà emmanuel macron a été élu avec une
majorité d'électeurs venu de la gauche
d'ailleurs tous ses collaborateurs
étaient des strauss kahniens c'était des
enfants de dominique strauss-kahn son
équipe de la campagne de 2017 et aux
européennes de 2019 cet électorat de
centre gauche a en partie abandonnée
emmanuel macron pour les verts que ce
soit aux européennes aux municipales et
cet électorat de centre gauche a été
remplacé notre guillemets par un
électorat venus du centre droit qui a
lui abandonné définitivement et l'air
puisque après tout autre fillon 20%
voiliers et bellamy 8% il ya quand même
beaucoup de 2,2 de pertes sans compter
les abstentionnistes et une partie de
l'électorat du centre droit est venu
renforcer la majorité macro nien
car ils étaient effrayés par les gilets
jaunes et il a apprécié la fermeté
répressive du pouvoir
voyez ce ce remplacement des lectorats a
fait que les socialistes se disent voilà
notre électorat est revenu au bercail
donc nous sommes
nous pouvons le récupère et donc ils
cherchent tous à reprendre cet électorat
qu'ils veulent arracher ouvert et c'est
pour ça qu anne hidalgo se dit pourquoi
pas moi parce qu'à paris en tout cas
elle a assez bien réussi à cannibaliser
la ligne idéologique écologique est là
et là et la volée si j'ose dire au vert
mais est ce que cette gauche là a encore
un électorat suffisant dans le pays pour
l'emporter alors que vous posez une très
bonne question parce que je pense que
non je pense que non en fait ils le
savent d'ailleurs puisque c'est ils font
tous le même calcul que macron c'est à
dire moi si j'arrive au second tour je
ne serai pas sa marine le pen et dans ce
cas là je gagnerai voyez il ya aussi ces
les poupées russes
il faut d'abord récupérer l'électorat de
gauche de macron arrivé au second tour
et être face à marine le pen
et dans ce cas là tout le monde gagne
c'est le jeu et sait plus à qui perd
gagne c'est qu'ils gagnent gagne donc ça
c'est ça le calcul évidemment vous avez
raison est-ce que ça permet d'être au
second tour en fait on est sur le
terreau terra nova c'est à dire que
c'est vous vous souvenez il ya une
dizaine d'années le cercle de réflexion
des socialistes terra nova avait
expliqué que la gauche avait perdu
définitivement le l'électorat ouvrier
l'électorat employés qui étaient absents
sionistes ont qui voter pour le
rassemblement front national l époque on
disait est il donc il fallait le
remplacer encore en toi et tu pars en
gros un électorat bobo des métropoles
des femmes diplômées et surtout le
renfort des enfants de l'immigration
dans les banlieues ouvriers se cette
alliance qui est terra nova qui est le
terreau sociologiques et politiques de
tous les candidats dont on parle on est
loin du parti socialiste d'avant le
parti socialiste en fait qui était une
espèce de front de classe
inspiré de jaurès et de blum synthèse
entre
la classe ouvrière française des
employés une petite classe moyenne et
une élite bourgeoise qui dirigeait tout
cela qui s'appelait jaurès blum
mitterrand était ce ce front de classe
est mort dans les années 80 puisque les
socialistes ont alors abandonné le
peuple au nom de l'europe et abandonner
la classe ouvrière au nom du libre
échange puisqu'on a eu la
désindustrialisation et au nom du
multiculturalisme
voyez avec l'immigration d'origine
principalement musulmanes voiliers de
toute cette toute cette sociologie toute
cette démographie à bouleverser
complètement le la donne à gauche
merci eric zemmour